u.s surgeon general jerome adams has
been meeting with community groups to
encourage measures like mask wearing and
social distancing
and overcome mistrust of vaccines first
on cbs this morning dr adams will also
tell us about a new effort
this is so important to protect pregnant
women and new moms so good morning to
you
mr surgeon general before we get to this
new effort i do want to talk about
the comments yesterday by cdc director
robert redfield he said we could be
facing
the most difficult period in the public
health history of this country
that actually echoes something he said
way back in april
that the president criticized him for
said he had been misquoted
when you think about those two data
points is there anything
that you wish the task force or you
yourself personally had said or done
differently to avoid this crisis that
we're in right now
well you ask a fair question and i think
i i wish that that i and i can only
speak for myself
had done a better job of communicating
the
uncertainty of this virus remember we're
still learning about it we're learning
new things every day and you saw new cdc
guidance on quarantine
and on testing come out and i have to
admit
that has confused the public when they
hear one thing one day
and it changes a few weeks or months
later but i want people to know that the
scientists are working hard around the
country at the cdc and at the fda
to give you the best recommendations
based on what we know now
and to continue to shift those
recommendations as the science warrants
and i want you to know
that we have great science that says
wearing a mask
and watching your distance and avoiding
contact outside of your household
will work to blunt this surge and
there's hope we're almost to a vaccine
so just hang on a little bit longer dr
adams i always appreciate your straight
talk on this so i want to pick up on one
more thing that dr redfield said he said
it was a problem his word a problem
that in the summer in july we were still
debating whether we should all be
wearing masks or not
out in public in addition to that
problem what else stood out to you about
the federal response to now
well one of the things that's
challenging in our country
is that we have a federalist system of
government
where all the states make up their own
minds and so one of the things we've
actively tried to do as doctors on the
task force
is go out to states and i'm high risk
myself but i've been to
uh i've been to states all over the
country been to cleveland uh been out to
uh
been out west to oklahoma been all over
the place trying to help people
understand their numbers on the ground
and we're seeing it work uh you hear a
lot of doom and gloom
but more people than ever are wearing
masks you saw holiday travel actually
decreased this year
compared to last year and so i want to
congratulate those people and tell
everyone else
hang on because we are in the midst of a
really bad surge
but uh what we do today will control
what happens weeks from now hang on
there is light at the end of the
tunnel dr adams it's good to see you i
want to talk about your call to action
to reduce maternal mortality in this
country i think many people would be
even surprised to hear that it is an
issue
what are you here to tell us about that
well gail thank you so much for the
opportunity we
have a coveted crisis in this country
but i want people to know we have a
maternal health
crisis in this country also with a woman
dying
a mom a mother-to-be dying every 12
hours
due to pregnancy-related complications
this is worse than many other developed
nations and it's getting worse because
of covet 19
but i want people to know this is
unacceptable but it is not inevitable
the cdc says
two-thirds of these deaths are
preventable and it's higher i'm told in
black women why
is that and what should we be doing
about it
well this is just shocking to me as a
father of a young woman as a husband of
a wife who's high risk
my sister right now is pregnant and she
is at high risk and i want people to
know
that black women in american indian
alaska native women are two to three
times more likely to die
versus white women and it doesn't matter
if you
have a phd like one of my own public
health service officers shalon irving
but why is that due to hypertension why
is that happening
well we know what's happening in many
cases because these women aren't being
heard and so i want to call out the
joint commission's
speak up campaign we're really trying
with this call to action to empower
women to speak up
but we're also telling people to listen
to women we know there's bias we know
there's
quite frankly racism and legacies of
racism
that mean people aren't heard and it
doesn't matter if you're beyonce
beyonce had a severe pre-eclampsia or
serena williams the best athlete in the
world
almost died due to pulmonary embolism we
need to do a deeper dive
into these root causes we need to really
empower women to speak up and we need to
listen to them so i want people to go to
surgeongeneral.gov
check out my call to action because it's
not just about the women it's about
what we do around them employers can
provide breastfeeding
and more supports for women we have the
best healthcare role to play
thank you dr adams he's right thank you
we haven't heard about serena williams
he is
yes we have the best best health care
system in the country but everyone needs
access to it equally
surgeon general thank you very much
jerome adams we appreciate it